I know.
[Silence]
So they
Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Continuing
in
the book of purification, the chapters
regarding
how one goes about
purifying
a
or a filth that would compromise his or
her salah.
This subchapter here is regarding
purifying a person's clothing
from al-medi.
What is almedi?
pre-jaculate.
it is
[Silence]
that this is usually something that
comes out of a person's genitals
during sexual arousal. This goes for
both men and women. It has a
description. We've mentioned it many
times before.
Now, what is the ruling on Ali? And medi
has two places that it would come into
contact with on a person's body. Number
one, a person's clothing. Number two, a
person's body. One of the interesting
points of filth.
One, we wouldn't call it an anomaly, but
a curiosity for sure is that it has a
different ruling on each of these two
places.
Because we've mentioned before what the
first principle
that we were going to take. We took two
principles. The first one with respect
to getting into this chapter and
understanding it is that what
that the purification of a naza is what?
Relative. It is relative to the place.
What is pure for the ground is not
necessarily pure for your clothing is
not necessarily pure for a man's
clothing is not necessarily pure for a
woman's clothing is not necessarily pure
for your body there are degrees
there is a gradation
and so with respect to ali
it has a different ruling for the body
than it does for the clothing as the
prophet sallallahu alaih Wasallam
will explain.
[Silence]
No
is washing
is bathing.
He thought because it was associated
with arousal that he had to take a bath.
He had to bathe. Could you imagine the
dedication it would take to bathe every
time something this happened?
living out in the desert winter and
summer. I mean it's unbelievable. It'd
be tough even for us in our mo in our
modernity to bathe at every junction.
And so
he says,
for
[Silence]
Allah. foreign.
He says and
or both have been mentioned
as the pronunciation of his father's
name.
He says, "I used to have a lot of
this pre-perm get on my clothing and
I used to have frequent bouts of it
and I used to constantly be bathing
every time I would see it and so things
were difficult for him. So I mentioned
this to the messenger of Allah Sam
and he said it is enough for you to
merely make wuboo.
So all of that suffering of bathing
every time, all of that hardship of
bathing, bathing, bathing, bathing, is
that from Allah or was that from
he is the one that wishes to push a
person over the edge. Shan will whisper
to you to try to get you to turn away
from Allah. But if he sees that you are
resilient and you are insisting on going
to Allah, he'll then start whispering in
your ear, "Run, run, run, run, run, run,
don't breathe, don't breathe, don't
breathe, to try to break you." All
right? To try to break you. He will
become the most vigilant person with
respect to your wudoo, your salah, your
your marriage, your marital status.
He will be the most vigilant one. He
will be questioning just to make sure
that everything is okay because his your
salah really matters to a shan and your
purity from a nasa really matters to a
shan, right? And so the idea here is
that a shaitan he will approach people
in different ways based on the kind of
person each one of us is. There are
those of us who are more inclined to be
extreme. And so he'll push us as far as
he can onto that direction. There are
those of us who are more inclined to
laziness. He will push us as far as he
can into that direction. There are those
of us who are more inclined to
knowledge. So he will push us as far as
he can into that direction. The
companions in used to say
it's been said that a shan's endgame
in his plotting he may help to open 99
good doors in a person's life just so
that he can manage to open one foul door
upon that person. And so the prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam said it's enough
for you to merely make wudoo. Imagine
how his life changed with this sentence
here. How much time was he spending
bathing this young manif
and now with one sentence of guidance
his whole life changed that moment.
And so he then said, "Oh messenger of
Allah, what about that of it which comes
in contact with my clothing?" He says,
"It is enough for you to take a handful
of water and to
sprinkle it or spray it onto your
clothing wherever you see that it may
have come in contact. So you don't have
to wash
to take a handful of water and put it
wherever it is on the clothing.
You don't have to scrub it. You don't
have to wash it. You don't have to right
that is enough.
in the narration of Ali
of course Ali couldn't ask such
questions of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam because he was married
to who? To his daughter. So he found it
inappropriate. He was too ashamed to ask
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
about something
that is remotely sexual in nature.
being that his daughter Fatima is his
wife and so he sent to him
to go ask him and so he went to ask for
a friend you know the old
cliche at the doctor's office not me
doctor it's just a friend of mine I'm
asking for a friend right and So he he
asked him and the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam said in that narration.
He said in that narration
that
with respect to a person who has this
discharge, he is to wash his genitals
wherever it is on his genitals and make
wool and make salah. And here we have
another wherever it is on the clothing.
So with respect to the clothing,
it is what?
With respect to the actual body, it is
what? To wash and to make.
None of the scholars view this as being
something that warrants a bath bathing.
And so that narration would have
actually been a little bit more
appropriate for this part in the book.
However, I believe that the author
placed this here because the narration
of Ali came before we already passed
that in the chapter regarding a neet and
he'll mention it another time as well
when we get to those things that break a
person's will. And so
when we take this narration and that
narration together we come up with a
conclusion and that is ali where it is
on the clothing water is placed where it
is on the body it is washed off is
enough but needs to be washed from both
clothing and from and from body. We will
continue this inshallah
tomorrow. I believe that
tomorrow and after tomorrow we should
finish this chapter and then go into
Subhan Allah.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Am I learning being a wine wer